economía en france 24 está conmigo en el
estudio mi compañera daniela blandón
daniela buenas noches comenzamos
hablando del balance en materia
económica con el que llega el mundo a
esta asamblea general virtual virtual de
la onu así de santiago muy buenas noches
pues sin duda este es un año excepcional
la economía global no iba también ya en
2019 creció en moderado 2,5 por ciento
pero a comienzos de ese año había
mejores perspectivas por supuesto que
las que hay ahora la llegada de la
pandemia encendió las alarmas y ahora se
cree que la economía va a caer entre el
47 por ciento y hasta un 75 por ciento
según organismos como el fondo monetario
internacional la ocde y el banco mundial
con este panorama llegan hoy los países
a la asamblea general de la onu como
usted lo decía pero económicamente
hablando también hubo un jalón de orejas
para eeuu y china y no precisamente por
temas relacionados con pandemia debemos
hacer todo lo posible para evitar una
nueva guerra fría estamos avanzando en
una dirección muy peligrosa nuestro
mundo no puede permitirse un futuro en
el que las dos economías más grandes
dividan el mundo
una gran fractura cada una con sus
propias reglas comerciales y financieras
y capacidades de inteligencia artificial
e internet
daniela y en la región de américa latina
si hay un país golpeado esa argentina
tercer año en recesión sí señor el
producto interno bruto de este país cayó
un 19.1 por ciento interanual en el
segundo trimestre de este año es decir
comparado con el mismo período del año
pasado esto no solamente representa la
mayor caída interanual desde que
iniciaron registros en 1981 también
implica que el país lleva nueve
trimestres consecutivos sin crecimiento
económico por eso se está encaminando
como usted lo decía a su tercer año
consecutivo en recesión en 2018 la
contracción fue del 2,5 por ciento
santiago pero en 2019 ya iba mejorando
hasta el 2,2 por ciento sin embargo este
año por el efecto de la pandemia el
gobierno espera que se desplome en una
caída mayor al 12% hablemos ahora de
aeronáutica hay polémica en torno a la
aerolínea avianca pues además de los
efectos de la pandemia primero surgió un
debate hace unas semanas porque el
gobierno colombiano le iba a hacer
estamos a la aerolínea por 370 millones
de dólares pero ese desembolso quedó
suspendido en tribunales ahora el centro
de la polémica santiago tiene que ver
con unos 7 millones de dólares en
bonificaciones que recibieron sus
directivos en plena pandemia
avianca inició en mayo un proceso de
reorganización en eeuu y justamente el
vídeo que la prueba en un plan de
financiamiento por 2 mil millones de
dólares pero como parte de ese plan de
aerolínea reconoció haber autorizado
pagos relacionados con un plan de
retención para su equipo directivo para
que ellos se queden en la empresa
durante todo el proceso de
reorganización las críticas vienen por
el lado de quienes dicen que estas
millonarias compensaciones se hicieron
al mismo tiempo que cientos de empleados
fueron despedidos hablemos ahora de ese
nuevo round en la pelea por el oro
venezolano que hay en el reino unido-
qué es lo que pasa pero la justicia
británica está reexaminando a partir de
hoy el caso con el que se busca definir
quién es el que tiene el poder sobre el
oro esta es una disputa que viene desde
comienzos de este año y tiene que ver
con lingotes por casi mil millones de
dólares que reposan en las bóvedas
inglaterra el gobierno de nicolás maduro
pidió retirar esa reserva para ayudar en
la crisis por el coronavirus y la
oposición no rechaza en primera
instancia se dijo que juan guaidó era
quien tenía la autoridad para
administrar estos recursos pero la
decisión fue recurrida y hoy inició una
nueva ronda en el tribunal de
apelaciones de londres el turno de la
audiencia fue para el equipo legal de
maduro y el miércoles lo hace la
oposición para que el tribunal
finalmente tome su decisión santiago
podemos hablar de indicadores como los
suelos principales bolsas del mundo en
la forma o street end se recuperó
levemente de una mala racha de varios
días sus principales índices subieron a
pesar de la incertidumbre política en
eeuu las bolsas europeas entretanto
cerraron con resultados dispares en
medio del temor por las nuevas medidas
de confinamiento decretadas en algunos
países y en américa latina hubo subidas
aunque bastante tímidas también se están
recuperando de algunas sesiones a la
baja de días anteriores sobre para el
cierre las cifras del día sorpréndanos
bueno son los 11 billones de dólares que
según el g20 se han inyectado a la
economía global para contrarrestar todos
estos efectos de la pandemia
coronavirus esto equivale santiago para
que se haga la idea la mitad del pib de
eeuu si lo que nos falta daniela muchas
gracias por esta información es todo por
el momento en economía en france 24 siga
con nosotros
i